all right y'all good morning
coffee okay i know i said i'd quit
yesterday i just
lied and didn't mean it
y'all okay i was recruiting
for the show tonight
and let me tell you
this one podcast has a similar amount of
subscribers i mean they have 3 000 more
and they're like
oh are you gonna pay us i'm like
no
sorry
like i can't uh at this point i will you
know maybe in the future but like
it's a bigger guess to no events
like i'm like sir you have 3 000 more
subscribers than me uh no i'm not going
to pay you
anyways
i'm like the audacity no i mean everyone
has a right to ask for what they want
but am i going to give it to you
no
not for 30k subs
no no sir
maybe when i start making more money
donate send money
okay anyways so let's talk about
let's talk about
the evolution of friendships
so this is what i've noticed okay
in friendship so
two people become friends
or lovers you know whatever
they hit it off immediately their best
friends
like besties all right
it takes about three months of like pure
bliss before they start to notice
the issues with each other i mean they
might notice small things but like
big issues they have with each other and
the way
the other one lives their life right
that's a little hot a little hot
and
i think i've noticed that friendships
fizzle out between like three and six
months and i think if you make it past
like
the six month-ish period where you're
hanging out together and like doing a
lot of stuff a lot
i think you'll make it for the long haul
as friends or at least for a couple
years until one of you moves
you're not in the same place but like
i feel like six months of like solid
friendship you can call that person
forever and like ask them
to stay with them
so tell my families who would always ask
to stay with other people
i don't know just something i've noticed
because at about three months you start
to realize like oh that's kind of weird
about them or they do that or they kind
of have a big mouth or whatever the
problem is everyone's got issues like
they notice it vice versa too so a lot
of times girls will get jealous of if
you have a close friend and they start
making friends with another friend but i
always just kind of wait i'm like oh
it'll fizzle out
give it give it three to six months
it'll fizzle and it literally always
does like clockwork
or they make it and i end up liking that
person so it's like mutual and we both
have a friend
um
i don't know this probably wasn't any
godly insight today but
i don't know morning coffee chat that's
all i got for you let me know in the
comments if you could think of something
more interesting
i can put out for morning coffee chat
next time and let me know if any of you
would be interested in a patreon if i
started one
and if so
what would you be willing to pay like
five dollars a month for for like
exclusive content like what type of
content would you want to see
anyways let me know in the comments bye